just days after Donald Trump tweeted
that he's going to help create Chinese
jobs Trump forged a deal with a company
called ZTE and lo and behold Ivanka
Trump's business all of a sudden has
five new trademarks approved in China it
is the height of swamp filling and to
refresh your memory remember when China
was a bad actor according to Donald
Trump
China was taking advantage of us China
was killing us on trade deals China
deserves to be tariffed and taxed and
sanctioned and all of that stuff we must
punish China for taking our jobs and we
are going to change geopolitics and
start winning against China again well
two weeks ago all of a sudden Donald
Trump wanted to help China he wanted to
help China get jobs back and this went
back to American sanctions of a Chinese
company called ZTE which had been fined
for selling illegally to Iran in North
Korea and Donald Trump said that the
penalty that was imposed on them by US
regulators was too harsh and actually
tweeted and we went over this a couple
of weeks ago President Xi of China and I
are working together to give massive
Chinese phone companies ZTE a way to get
back into business fast too many jobs in
China lost Commerce Department has been
instructed to get it done it was very
weird but we also learned around the
same time that the Chinese government
agreed to give a 500 million dollar loan
to a state-owned construction company to
build an Indonesian theme park featuring
none other than Trump branded golf
courses and a Trump branded hotel that's
what we knew last week it was sick it
was a disgusting instance of apparent
corruption and it's even worse now
because not only is Donald Trump saying
that he's working on dropping those
prohibitions against the Chinese company
ZTE we have now learned that just a few
days before this entire thing started
Ivanka Trump's business received five
new trademarks from the Chinese
government with these trademarks her
company is going to be able to make a
bunch of different products in China
that would be profitable to the tune of
many millions of dollars so let
look at the timeline as we now
understand it for years Trump says China
is bad but like really really bad on May
7th
Ivanka Trump's company is granted five
new Chinese trademarks three days later
we learned that China agreed to a 500
million dollar loan for a Trump linked
Indonesia project and then on May 13th
Donald Trump all of a sudden starts
tweeting support for Chinese jobs what's
surprising and coincidental timing right
and this is one of those things where if
you all along weren't believing that
Donald Trump was going to drain the
swamp or to change how business and
lobbying are done in the United States
or whatever else this wouldn't be
surprising for you if you fell for
Trump's BS then maybe you would be
disturbed by this but I'm actually
worried that it will have no impact
because the real tragedy here is that
the trumpets won't really care and
they've already started to say things if
you look online in the normal enclaves
and recesses of the internet where the
Trump is liked to hang out there already
saying things like Obama did stuff like
this and he never got in trouble Hillary
Clinton would have done stuff like this
and she never got in trouble you'll
often hear the term Clinton Foundation
thrown around in there
Trump's just smart for taking advantage
of the system he he shouldn't be singled
out and of course my only commentary on
that is vote in November because there
is no other way forward when it comes to
this stuff we are not going to see
trumpets hold Trump accountable for this
and I don't even think we are we are
going to see regulators hold Trump
accountable for this stuff the only way
forward is to vote in November and I
hope that you will and I know you're
probably sick of hearing me say it but
I'm gonna have to keep saying it and Pat
is very sick of hearing me say it that I
can assure you're gonna have to say it
more and more though I know we are and
and I've been saying it off air as well
like I'll come in the morning and talk
to Pat about how he needs to vote in
November please vote in November and you
can discuss this and any other story
with us on our reddit on our subreddit
at david pakman.com slash our IDI di t
today's
episode of the program is made possible
in part by Cody a new innovative
cryptocurrency and online payment
platform that's setting out to
revolutionize how payments are sent and
received online what Cody stands for is
currency of the internet and most
Kryptos out there today simply weren't
designed for online payments and the
goal of the Cody crypto is to achieve an
infrastructure for online payments that
simple transparent trustworthy
instantaneous and scalable which no
blockchain for payments has really
achieved to date so Cody is aiming to be
that missing piece of the puzzle a
crypto and platform actually designed
with online payments in mind if you're
watching this on youtube you can find
out more about Cody and their ICO by
using the links below the video this is
not financial advice and should not be
interpreted as such and everybody should
do their own research on any project
that they're interested in